ja ganz anderes thema wer will wer will
wer hat noch nicht moral ist derzeit
wieder ganz groß im sommerschlussverkauf
alles muss raus denn wir haben olympia
und alle welt die menschenrechts
organisationen weisen jetzt auch die
schlimme menschenrechtslage in china hin
da haben sie recht das ist auch schlimm
es war eigentlich schon immer schlimm
die bundesregierung fährt auch nicht
nach china zu den olympischen
winterspielen und wird keine
staatssekretärs delegation geben die
fährt dann erst wieder hinterher da hin
und macht einen offiziellen
arbeitsbesuch jetzt zu den olympischen
spielen gibt es das nicht und mir kann
keiner so richtig erklären warum
ist eigentlich die hohe moral immer bei
den sportveranstaltungen da und da muss
boykottiert werden da muss man in
wegbleiben und hinterher fährt man zum
ganz normalen arbeitsmarkt wieder
geschäfte wir alle tragen made in china
irgendwelche masken wir nutzen die
testkits wir haben die t-shirts an vw
hat einen riesenberg in der
inkriminierten uiguren regionen chinas
tibet geht es schon immer schlecht
hongkong
verschlechtert sich die
menschenrechtslage auch ständig aber
wenn es um olympia gibt dann gibt es die
ganz großen boykott forderungen der
milliardär und großinvestor george soros
hat sogar die olympischen spiele 1936
verglichen das finde ich einen gewagten
vergleich ich kenne nicht den anteil des
china geschäfts am vermögen von herrn
schorr roche muss mich aber einfach
wundern warum wird dieses thema immer
aufgemacht wenn es um sport geht und
nicht wenn es um die ganz normalen
geschäfte geht die wir ständig dort
abschließend das kann mir keiner
erklären wir müssen uns endlich mal
entscheiden ist sport eigentlich
völkerverständigung oder ist es
diktatoren deko wenn es letzteres ist
dann müssen wir es lassen ansonsten
reisen auch unsere sportler als
botschafter des beim essen sein und
haben die gleichen chancen für unser
system zu werben für die freie welt zu
werben für die freien ideen und die
freien meinung zu werden und ich bin da
nicht bange dass uns das auch gelingen
wird
reife das kann mir ja genauso
unterstützen noch weiter weiterführen
also ich meine bei einer werte basierten
außenpolitik durch vw erwähnt wir
könnten genauso
mercedes erwähnen mercedes hat im
letzten jahr mehr autos verkauft in
china als im ganzen rest der welt
mercedes hauptwerk oder und auch die
konzernzentrale in stuttgart stuttgart
ist der sitz der baden württembergischen
landesregierung die wird angeführt von
herr kretschmann der grüne
ministerpräsident der einzigen bisher
könnte doch jeden tag dorthin gehen ins
werk und zum vorstandsvorsitzenden und
sagen freunde nicht mit mir und alle
möglichen bestimmungen ins werk setzen
zusammen mit frau berbalk dass das
aufhört ich habe vor mehr als zehn
jahren auf dem münchner marienplatz
gestanden und demonstriert für die
olympischen spiele in münchen und in
garmisch partenkirchen mit kati witt ich
war ganz geehrt daneben wir stehen zu
dürfen und vielen anderen sportlern
hintergrund war dass das unternehmen
führt er sich damals gearbeitet hatte
olympia sponsor war und der ja die die
wolken gerne alle zusammen erreichen
dass die olympischen spiele nach münchen
kommen geleitet wurde das deutsche
olympische komitee damals von einem
grünen michael vesper der versprochen
hatte nachhaltigkeit zu bringen in
dieser olympischen spiele und
nachhaltige ideen und die ersten grünen
spiele daraus zu machen trotzdem hat die
bevölkerung in münchen in garmisch und
in zwei anderen landkreisen mehrheitlich
und in jedem landkreis abgelehnt dass
diese spiele da hinkommen nein da wollen
wir nicht bausünden verkehr so ein dreck
wollen wir gar nicht haben umwelt
verpesten das waren die gründe warum
diese olympischen spiele nicht in
deutschland stattfinden und china hat ja
gesagt wir sehen das gleich mit den
olympischen spielen 20 26 und den
kommenden wo es auch solche
auseinandersetzung gegeben hat und die
bevölkerung gesagt haben in manchen
ländern das wollen wir nicht haben also
wer sich hier beschwert soll am ende
nicht sagen warum gibt es nicht bei uns
oder zu unseren zu unseren umständen
oder in unseren gefilden der nicht sagt
wir sind bereit so was auch durch aber
ich finde eine sache interessant bei
dieser freiheit des boykotts das in den
usa hat das anders als in europa gelingt
zumindest eine einigkeit herzustellen
dass man eben diese spiele boykottiert
und jetzt würde ich nicht sagen dass es
den usa wirtschaftlich wahnsinnig
schlechter geht oder sie sozusagen unter
der werte basierten außenpolitik der
vergangenen jahrzehnte gelitten haben im
gegenteil die usa sagen jetzt wir müssen
unsere wirtschaft auch deshalb in den
usa wieder stärken zum beispiel die
chip-produktion die massiv ausgebaut
wird auch in den usa und ich finde es
problematisch insbesondere bei den
grünen in diesen tagen dass wir da vor
der wahl ganz ganz viel gehört haben die
armen menschen in hongkong was deinen
taiwan passiert was der präsident chinas
tut und natürlich würde müssten wir
müssen wir müssen und davon hört man
plötzlich gar nichts mehr also natürlich
hat vw habe ja viel zu tun jetzt mit der
russlandkrise ich weiß nicht wie viel
einfluss die dann tatsächlich wirklich
hart aber was jetzt die china politik
angeht was hongkong an die dhabi noch
gar nichts gehört ich war viele viele
jahre in hongkong gehabt da viele
aktivisten immer wieder berichtet seit
2014 viele aktivisten getroffen den
haben wir mal hier nach deutschland
geholt da gab es riesen alarm dann
direkt von der chinesischen regierung
das darf heiko maas in die hand
geschüttelt hat und aber vor allem die
grünen waren hinterher und haben gesagt
wir müssen denen helfen die sind jetzt
internet hat seitdem sie in der
regierung sind höre ich nichts mehr die
grünen haben da jede menge
betätigungsfeld sie können
beispielsweise wie es übrigens die
kanzlerin mal gemacht hat den dalai lama
empfangen dann viel spaß hinterher mit
den reaktionen aus china das wäre aber
mutig sie können auch mal ein zeichen
setzen und die taipeh vertretung von
taiwan besuchen wo es im augenblick
ziemlich brenzlig ist da kann man schon
ganz gut mal statt uhr zeigen warum das
immer beim sport ist wo es eigentlich
nichts kostet das habe ich nie so
richtig verstanden ich habe den berg
kräftige meisten von uns nicht bewusst
erlebt es gibt in zweibrücken einmal
1980 und die sowjetunion die damalige
geld in afghanistan einmarschiert ist an
gab es einen boykott das fest nicht
kennen jemand hat sich der da hätte
laufen sollen vom deutschen team
mittelstreckenläufer konnte er nicht das
war seine einzige richtige chance und
das
eine medaille zu gewinnen also insofern
leider vergebens und dann 1984 die
reaktion ist damaligen ostblocks die
olympischen spiele in los angeles die
dann eben von der seite als quid pro quo
auch boykottiert worden waren zwar auch
toll die spieler los angeles aber
trotzdem es bringt ja überhaupt nicht
und ganz im gegenteil eigentlich ist der
olympische geist auch in krisen
zusammenzukommen und krisen zu
überwinden durch das zusammenkommen
deswegen kann ich auch diesen boykott
nicht als goldene idee nachvollziehen im
gegenteil man muss ja auch einfach mal
eine sache sagen es gibt hier auch
sachen die china durchaus sehr gut
gemacht hat also gerade ich muss das
thema corona er mit zahlen nochmal
einmal einbringt gerade in kronach
fragen hier heute morgen mal geguckt
also china hat 1,74 milliarden einwohner
1,2 1,4 sogar und die haben 106000
kroner infektion gehabt und nur 4600
menschen sind gestorben wie ehrlich die
statistiken sind und was da im labor
wirklich passiert ist haben sie nie
schlechter als bei uns hier in
deutschland also ich glaube zumindest
wenn sie sehr viel negativer werden wäre
die möglichkeit größer dass in china die
statistiken doch etwas anders
dargestellt werden ja aber ich finde es
interessant wie das sind die oft die
werden ja offiziell geführt ich könnte
mir meine eigenen gedanken dazu machen
ganz klar aber ich finde das schon
beeindruckend und das sollte man einfach
mal erwähnen also ich weiß nicht was die
gemacht haben wir haben ja damals diesen
super lock down gesehen wo wir alle im
fernsehen geguckt haben usw fanden wir
es jetzt gut oder fanden wir es schlecht
ich glaube fand es irgendwie schlecht
aber so ähnliches zeugs haben wir dann
hier auch gekriegt und wir haben aber
100 13.000 menschen die das muss ja auch
mal jemand erklären warum es bei uns so
schlecht gelaufen ist oder ist es bei
denen auch schlecht gelaufen wir gehen
jetzt nicht noch einmal ganz groß
zurückzuholen also viel zeit haben wir
nicht mehr so abschließendes plädoyer
von der aif wir sollten es nicht
boykottieren ich finde man sollte
hingehen man sollte darüber reden und
bei jedem normalen staatsbesuch kriegen
wir von china demonstriert dass sie am
längeren hebel sitzen bei jedem
staatsbesuchen ich bin oft mit merkel
dort gewesen gibt es abends einen
empfang in der botschaft jedes mal
werden dissidenten eingeladen und jedes
mal können die leider nicht kommen weil
jemand vor ihrer tür steht und ihnen
empfiehlt nicht dass hinzugehen und das
empfiehlt er sehr nachdrücklich das
lassen wir uns jedes mal gefallen also
wenn schon dann keinen gratis mit bei
sport sondern mut im alltag und mut eben
auch bei geschäften wo es wehtut
ich finde das war ein sehr schönes
schlussplädoyer für unsere sendung heute
abend herzlichen dank dass sie
zugeschaut haben ganz ganz lieben dank
an meine gäste tom larsen ralf schuler
paul ronzheimer und béla anda und da ich
auch autorin zeige ich doch noch mal das
buch schauen ist diesmal an schönen
abend noch und wenn sie mögen
dienstagabend sehen wir uns wieder
[Musik]
[Applaus]